[Musique]
j'avais déjà vu mais c'est assez rare
quand même et je me rappelle très bien
d'avoir un énorme trou de mémoire et de
dirhams et régisseur mais il ya aidez
moi c'est quoi le texte et je vois juste
mais régisseur avec une manette comme ça
peut faire
c'est pas
ne faisait pas arrivé trop de fois on
était quand même assez sage qui un soir
je vais retrouver mémoire là c'est
marrant comme un trou de mémoire si tu
cherches et en mettant sur des trucs
donc tu as un cerveau qui sépare et donc
après ce gros trou ne manque que j'avais
vu le lendemain j'avais embrassé le
texte je me dis lui avait dit me lâche
pas et il m'a pas lâché du coup c'est
devenu un réflexe me sucrer et moi même
espèce de truc à la con et depuis je
n'ai pas trouvé c'est peut-être que ça
marche au début c'est terrifiant et puis
un moment quand on a un peu plus
d'expérience c'est rigolo parce que les
gens il faut tant que joueur ça aussi
j'ai jamais attendait ça y est toutefois
resté ouvre toi c'est du vrai bois cet
homme a choisi le truc de trous noirs et
il marche bien parce que c'est vraiment
visuellement ce que tu ressens quoi
c'est surtout peut-être coûté aspiré par
le vis des jeunes est particulièrement
simple non j'étais un peu genre
spécialiste du trou de mémoire donc
notamment quand j'ai repris mon
spectacle après les dix mois de 1ère
pandémie et je crois que je dispute un
pouvoir 14 trouve donc juste également
avec mon texte sur scène et les gens
plutôt assisté un spectacle sur un mec
aux blessures texte en fait
[Musique]
moi j'ai des potes restaurateurs quand
je vais chez eux j'aime bien payés et
j'aime bien les gens pays trottiner noir
spectacle et ça tellement de fois dès
que je peux juste de ma notoriété
franchement si ça sert à quelque chose
c'est bien ce à quoi oui et non on va en
fait on fait tout ça quand tu connais tu
pas là je suis allé voir michael
gregorio
j'ai oui j'ai envoyé un message à mika
et j'ai dit est ce que je peux venir te
voir une mamie de place bon je sais pas
si ça s'appelle se servir de sa
notoriété on peut dire oui on peut dire
oui oui on sait là oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui oui ça m'est arrivé d'avoir des gens
qui sont un petit peu intense j'ai eu
quelques fans compliqué comme il n'est
pas longtemps que c'était compliqué mais
basculer dans le harcèlement est
toujours à calmer les choses
j'ai déjà eu une super fan je vois c'est
une fan parce que pour moi c'est
flippant autre chose elle m'envoie un
message avec écrit regarde devant ta
porte au début je sais pas qui c'est je
fais ok je regarde
et je vois personne c'est encore plus
flippante india avec wii fit je regarde
moi d'avoir à 3 heures du matin il ya
personne je vous la porte et devant
importées vers un grand sac avec plein
de cadeaux dont
j'ai fait un sketch sur les rugbymans
avec des phrases et où il ya plein de
mecs qui vont envoyer les phrases tatoué
qui sont faits c'est qu il soit aussi
rigolo c'est des copains machin voilà
donc ce moment il ya des mecs qui sont à
trouver des phrases ça assez débile et
sa crypte inondé fois un peu collant des
fans collorec
mois
d'avril est la question alors si si mais
tous les gens qui imprime des photos
déjà et après je suis qu'il vient de
faire signer une photo ils ont ainsi
lieu
une troisième et priait 25e et la 30e et
gajan et est souvent quand elle ces
photos sont rangés dans un sac plastique
c'est encore plus vrai
que ça fait plaisir en même temps
c'était un mec ou genre il était comme
ça il faisait des trucs genre comme s'il
y avait un protocole principe tu vois tu
vas arrêter de faire des références à
des gens que tu fais là on a rigolé
[Musique]